♪[冒険風]〜
こちらに見えるダンボール…
多くね？
もう多分書いてるからわかると→
思うんですけど
こちらご覧ください！
ボールプールって子供のときに入った
ことある方多いと思うんですけども→
プールの形のところにカラーボール
たくさんあって　そこでこう→
あっきゃっきゃっ
あっきゃっきゃー
って遊ぶやつなんですけれども→
それを！82万円分買ってしましました
やべ。はいというわけで
今から何をしようかと言いますと…
はい！業者さんに頼んで
この部屋をボールプールでこう→
いい感じにプールにするときに
ボールって何個いりますか〜？って→
なんとなく聞いてみたら→
82万円かかりました(荒)
やっばいんだよなぁ…やばいけど→
オレは！！！！この歳になって
ボールプールに入ってみたくなった！
だが！お店によくある
ボールプールだと→
年齢制限12歳以下やら身長何cm以下やら
色々あって→
こんなおっきなぼくはもう↗︎
となると！ボールプールに入るときは
もう自分で作るしかないということで→
今日は大人が誰でも楽しめる最高の
ボールプールを作っていこうと思います
ではいこう！！！！
ちなみにぼくは値段は知っているが
ボールの数はまだ知っていない
(カメラマン)うーん↗︎
それが多いのか少ないかもわかんない
んでとりあえず運んでみます！
5万個でしょ？想像がつかないんだが。
1個目入りまぁす！1箱にどれぐらい
入ってるかがすごい気になりますね
うわすごい！めっちゃ綺麗！
ダァーー！！
[ﾀﾞﾊﾞﾀﾞﾊﾞﾀﾞﾊﾞ…]
アー！！
あっきゃっきゃっきゃっ
きゃっきゃっきゃっ
どんどんやります
うわぁー！うぉー！よいしょー！
うぉー！よいしょー！うぉー！
やばい　もう↗︎
1000個ぐらい入れたんですけど
もう歩けないです
赤いきまぁす！よいしょー！
あぁー！よいしょー！どうだー！
ぶぅー！あぁー！あぁー！
おー！おー！あー！
ちょっと足の踏み場がないので
1回ボールを奥の方にやりましょう
♪〜
整地が終わったので…
また…
タァ…(？)
運びま…
しょう…
あああ(疲)
すいません…汗が止まんないんで
一時的にシャツを着ます　すいません！
もーびっしょびしょすぎてやばい
マジできついぞこれ〜
♪〜
ヤバイ！
ハァ…ハァ…ハァ…
きつい！
やばい　どこだ？
これやばいぞー
え　ガチでヤバイ
え　どうすればいいの？これ。やばい！
♪[シリアス系]〜
ハッ…ハッ…ハッ…
♪〜
(以下、くぐもった声)
フッフッフッフッフ…
フッハッハッハッハ…
フーッハッハッハッハッハッハ…
わぁぁぁあああああぁぁあああ
わぁー　溺れる溺れる！
やばい…
待ってほんとにやばいｗ
わぁー！！
♪〜
はい　というわけでついに完成しました
ぼくは今年…
ナイトプールに行ってません
でも！！
はっはっはァ…(恍惚)
ボールプールの完成でーーす！！！！
[SE：「フゥー！イェーイ！」&拍手]
[ｻﾞﾊﾞｧ…]
ヒャッホォォウ！！
[ｻﾞﾊﾞｻﾞﾊﾞ…]
ワーハハ！！
アハハ！！
アハハ！？
ワーッ！！
ワーハハ！！
アハハァー！！
アーハハハ…
ハハハ…
ワァアアア？
アァ？
アァ？？
ア゛ァ？？
ウォーターボーイズ！！
♪〜
や　これ多分ね
マジで気持ちいいっすよ
高さ1mぐらいを確保されてて…。
奥の方なんて多分ぼくの身長ぐらいの
波がありますからね
行ってみましょうか
[ｶﾞｻ　ｶﾞｻ]
いや　これ　ちょ　待っ　やばい
ファ　これ　ちょっ…
なかなかやばいこれ。
移動がね　ほんとプールなんですよね
奥まで来ました！
相当深いプールになって
おりますこれは。
やーもう…やばいよ…これ…
たしか机がここに
あった気がするんすよね
あっ…出たい…
出たぞ
これ飛び込んでもケガしないよね？
さすがにこんだけあれば
大丈夫だと思います　いきます！
[ﾄﾞｻｧ]
痛くなぁい！
ファァァァァ！！！！
ピヤァァァァ
アハァ！！
あっはっは！！
ア！？
アーッハッハッハァ！？
♪〜
[通常ED]